dos personas murieron en el corazón de
París a finales de abril otra también
murió por disparos en la capital
francesa en octubre en 2021 Solo dos
automovilistas murieron a manos de la
policía tras desobedecer a la autoridad
en 2022 la cifra subió a 13 Un aumento
que para algunos coincide con el de la
desobediencia a la autoridad entre 2010
y 2019 el número de estas infracciones
aumentó en casi un 50% según el
observatorio francés de seguridad Vial
pero el abogado de la familia de la
adolescente muerto en ante pone
énfasis en que el uso de armas por parte
de la policía solo debe efectuarse en
caso de absoluta necesidad para que el
tiroteo fuera legal en la vida del
policía Tendría que haber estado en
peligro lo cual no fue el caso podemos
ver claramente en el video que a los
policías están a un lado en los últimos
años han aumentado los tiroteos a
vehículos en movimiento entre 2012 y
2016 596
y entre 2017 y 2021 837 un salto del 40%
en 2017 una ley amplió las condiciones
para que los policías dispararan los
policías nacionales pueden utilizar su
arma en particular en caso de amenaza a
su vida o integridad física así como
para inmovilizar un vehículo cuyos
ocupantes representen un peligro público
para la inspección general de la Policía
Nacional no hay un vínculo entre esta
ley y el aumento de tiroteos este
abogado prefiere señalar a la formación
que se le da a los policías
te das cuenta le damos a la policía un
arma letal le damos una herramienta que
causará muertes no los entrenamos en
absoluto para eso no los entrenamos
psicológica o tácticamente no los
entrenamos solo para usar la herramienta
disparan 90 rondas al año en tres
sesiones de 30 rondas según las pocas
estadísticas disponibles los policías
franceses utilizan más sus armas de
servicio que sus colegas de Inglaterra o
Alemania